Okay, only the Y on the mitochondrial chromosomes don't
undergo significant recombination of over many generations. Obviously you
know that chromosomes 1 through 22 do the autosomes.
And even the X chromosome does. Remember when you
have two X's in an individual, plenty of crossing
over goes on between those X's. In the X
and Y combination, they largely don't have a lot
of recombination. There are a couple of regions that can,
but very few. So over many generations, the Y chromosome
is left largely intact, whereas the X has plenty recombination that
goes on when it finds itself in combination with another X.
And of course the mitochondrial chromosome doesn't undergo recombination at all.